herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
[Musik]
ich glaube ich muss im heutigen Video
nicht erklären was gerade auf der Welt
los ist ihr habt wahrscheinlich alle das
schwere Erdbeben mitbekommen in der
Türkei
Syrien und
bisher sind ja wirklich viele Menschen
verstorben viele liegen noch unter den
Trümmern es sind viele Helfer vor Ort
aber die Überlebenden und die Verletzten
die jetzt gerade quasi die Katastrophe
überlebt haben und hoffentlich noch die
nächsten Tage geborgen werden
die brauchen alle unsere Hilfe
und wir haben heute Tag 2 quasi war
gestern die Katastrophe
wir haben uns überlegt wie wir helfen
können und in so Situationen gerade wenn
Umweltkatastrophen sind ist immer ganz
wichtig dass die ganze Menschheit
zusammenhält und ich finde dass da
einfach nicht drüber gesprochen werden
sollte was es für Nationen sind was ist
für Nationalitäten sind was ist für
Religionen sind Mensch ist Mensch und
jeder Mensch sollte anderen Menschen
helfen
deswegen haben wir uns überlegt wie wir
helfen können und es sind gerade viele
Hilfsorganisationen viele Spendenaufrufe
und
wir wollen jetzt hier keinen
Spendenaufruf starten denn ich habe zwar
eine eigene Sallys Stiftung aber meine
Stiftung ist quasi rechtlich nicht dazu
ausgelegt Naturkatastrophen zu helfen
das rechtlich muss man ehrlich sagen
deutsche Bürokratie immer bisschen
schwierig
[Musik]
meine Stiftung ist nur dafür da
hier in Deutschland zu helfen Bildung
Erziehung Ernährung das ist einfach eine
ganz andere
ein anderer Stiftungszweck geht nicht
ich möchte auch keine Spendengelder
sammeln weil wir das rechtlich einfach
nicht dürfen aber es gibt ganz viele
große Hilfsorganisationen wo ihr hin
spenden könnt und wir für uns als Sallys
Welt haben uns überlegt eigentlich
hatten wir gerade eine schöne
valentinstagsaktion geplant wo wir ganz
tolle liebevolle herzliche
Valentinstags Aktionen und Rabatte
machen wollten jetzt haben wir uns aber
als Firma überlegt wir möchten einfach
15 %
direkt als Sallys Firma in die Türkei
und nach Syrien Spenden überall dahin wo
Hilfe gebraucht wird wir suchen uns dann
eine Organisation von der wir einfach
auch wissen das Geld kommt dort eben an
nichtsdestotrotz man kann auch
helfen indem man nicht unbedingt Geld
spenden muss denn die Menschen dort
können gerade direkt mit Geld eigentlich
nichts anfangen das brauchen die
Hilfsorganisation die dort eben dafür
sorgen dass Menschen geborgen werden
dass Menschen Unterkünfte bekommen und
dass sie Hilfe bekommen und wir alle
können dennoch ganz viel Hilfe leisten
und was gerade online viel passiert ist
dass viele Spenden Sachspenden gesammelt
werden und dann eben in die Türkei
gefahren werden
da ist nur leider das Problem dass
vieles einfach unorganisiert stattfindet
und eben nicht geplant ist und gerade in
so Situationen muss man das wirklich gut
planen und sich auch Partnern die Hand
holen die das gut strukturieren wir
arbeiten jetzt hier mit dem türkischen
Konsulat zusammen weil wir da einfach
wissen dass die Hilfen ankommen das
heißt momentan gibt's auch einen Stau
auf den Strecken LKWs kommen nicht an
die Hilfen kommen nicht an und es ist
gerade ein riesen Chaos und was er jetzt
tun könnt ist wirklich
organisiert und strukturiert an die
Sache ran zu gehen
und zwar haben wir uns überlegt dass wir
unsere riesen sally-lkws die großen 40
Tonner losschicken das türkische
Konsulat sorgt dann auch dafür dass sie
dort in der Türkei ankommen das heißt
wir werden euch heute in diesem Video
zeigen wie ihr die drei oder wie ihr
Pakete packen könnt denn was die
Menschen dort nicht brauchen und das ist
ganz schlimm ich habe so vieles online
schon gesehen es werden alte Kleider
hingeschickt es werden alte Spielsachen
geschickt und die Menschen die gerade
Hilfe brauchen die brauchen eure alten
Sachen nicht diese Menschen brauchen
warme Kleidung diese Menschen brauchen
Hygieneartikel diese Menschen brauchen
Lebensmittel und ihr könnt eigentlich
vier verschiedene Pakete packen Paket 1
wäre ein lebensmittelpaket Paket zwei
wäre so ein SOS Kit ähm quasi in SOS
Paket mit hilfsartikeln zeige ich euch
gleich
Paket 3 ist ein hygienepaket und Paket 4
wären Textilien bei Textilien das werde
ich euch jetzt heute nicht zeigen aber
es gibt auch eine offizielle Liste die
Menschen brauchen decken die Menschen
brauchen Unterwäsche bitte frische
Unterwäsche keine getragenen alten
Sachen warme Schuhe
Mäntel Jacken Kleidung für Babys
Kleidung für
[Musik]
Kinder Erwachsene
alles was man eben braucht wenn man
draußen friert
genau und da bitte einfach frische neue
Ware weil es jetzt nicht darum geht
euren Kleiderschrank zu sortieren und
auszumisten sondern es geht darum
Menschen in Not zu helfen
gut
also Paket 1 lebensmittelpaket zeige ich
euch jetzt mal kurz und wichtig ist auch
dass die Helfer vor Ort die haben keine
Zeit oder Pakete auszupacken und zu
sortieren die Helfer vor Ort brauchen
beschriftete Pakete es muss drauf stehen
was drin ist damit die Hilfe wirklich
sofort ankommt Paket 1 wäre z.B ein
lebensmittelpaket und das habe ich jetzt
hier auch beschriftet Lebensmittel mit
damals die Liste kommt auch offiziell
vom türkischen Konsulat weil die uns
einfach gesagt haben was vor Ort
gebraucht wird was nicht gebraucht wird
sind Fleisch und ähm Käseprodukte
Produkte die verderben kein frisches
Obst und Gemüse bitte wirklich nur
Sachen die haltbar sind am besten auch
nichts im Glas verpackt denn durch den
Transport kann das natürlich beschädigt
werden und dann macht man mehr Probleme
als man Probleme löst alle Lebensmittel
die sättigen wie Reis Nudeln Linsen
Hülsenfrüchte allgemein Mehl Salz dass
man einfach Brot auch backen kann sich
ein Tee aufkochen kann der Teebeutel
sind ganz wichtig
was ich finde ich auch wichtig ist ich
meine das sind jetzt alles Produkte die
man dann vor Ort quasi noch warm machen
Backen erhitzen muss ist zum Beispiel
auch Nüsse
Reiswaffeln Maiswaffeln alles was quasi
sättigt und einem Energie gibt kann man
wirklich mit hinschicken
Babynahrung auch ganz wichtig wichtig
wäre einfach wirklich kein Fleisch keine
Käseprodukte und einfach Artikel die
nicht kaputt gehen die nicht auslaufen
und falls ihr doch was habt was
irgendwie schwierig verpackt ist
vielleicht noch mal um verpacken quasi
noch mal eine Folie drum zu kleben das
ist einfach sicher ist am besten sind
wirklich Konserven weil Konserven sehr
gut haltbar sind Konserven gehen nicht
kaputt und die kann man ganz gut
transportieren die packt ihr dann in
einen Karton
und dann klebt ihr den Karton zu und
dann schreibt ihr oben drauf
weil in der Türkei dass die eben wissen
was drin ist und was drauf ist und wir
werden es dann so machen das erzähle ich
euch noch am Ende dass wir
die Kartons dann quasi sammeln alle in
den LKW packen und dann eben in die
Türkei schicken und für den Fall dass
auch unser LKW gestoppt wird weil die
Straßen voll sind die türkische Airlines
die Fliegen gerade jeden Tag in die
Türkei hin und zurück und bringen dort
die ganzen Hilfen auch hin und da sind
wir gerade im Gespräch dass falls unser
LKW doch nicht
durchkäme das wird vorher geklärt dass
dann die Türkisch Airlines eben alle
Pakete mitnimmt und wirklich kostenlos
in die Türkei in die Regionen geschickt
wurde Hilfe gebraucht wird
okay wir packen mal den Karton
das zweite Paket das ist das SOS Paket
die einmalsemelage das ist quasi ein
Paket was man braucht
wenn man keinen Strom hat und quasi
keine Unterkunft es werden noch Zelte
gebraucht es werden Betten gebraucht
Matratzen gebraucht die können wir jetzt
hier nicht mit reinpacken aber es werden
Kissen gebraucht Decken Pflaster
Feuchttücher Taschentücher Thermoskanne
Wärmeflasche
Cremes eine Powerbank wäre auch ganz
wichtig Powerbank und Kabel weil die
Menschen dort wenn Sie Ihr Smartphone
noch bei sich haben dass sie eben auch
ihre Familien erreichen können Hilfe
rufen können
Taschenlampe Batterien da ist auch drauf
zu achten dass einfach diese Kabelbinder
weggeschnitten sind weil oft ja auch
keine Schere oder kein Messer da ist und
das wäre quasi so das SOS Paket und das
bitte dann auch so beschriften
und wichtig natürlich auch wenn
Taschenlampen da sind auch direkt die
Batterien Menschen
[Musik]
dann haben wir Paket Nummer 3
Hygieneartikel hier und Bebek also auch
Babyartikel da ist eigentlich auch alles
wichtig Windeln
Damenhygieneartikel Taschentücher Seife
Duschgel Shampoo Feuchttücher
stellt euch da einfach vor alles was ihr
braucht wenn ihr an eure Körperhygiene
unter den Körper Bedarf denkt Pflaster
Desinfektionsmittel Babyflaschen
Toilettenpapier aber auch Rasierer
Rasierschaum Zahnbürsten Zahnpasta
eigentlich alles für den täglichen
Bedarf da ist auch wichtig dass ihr
schaut dass die Sachen gut verpackt sind
wir haben das jetzt hier auch noch mal
extra zugeklebt das einfach nichts
ausläuft und nichts aus Glas ist
also das sind jetzt hier quasi die drei
Pakete wie gesagt Lebensmittel SOS Paket
und das hygienepaket und wir haben jetzt
überlegt wie wir das machen wollen ähm
wir machen jetzt keine Sammelstelle
sondern ihr könnt gerne die Pakete
verpacken bitte sicher verpacken gut
beschriften und dann zu uns in den
Onlineshop schicken nach Sulz am Neckar
die Adresse blenden wir ein und am
besten die nächsten 123 Tage damit es
noch vor dem Wochenende ankommt und
unser LKW das dann quasi zum Wochenende
eben in die Türkei fahren kann oder dass
wir zum Wochenende die Pakete dann
verschicken können und ich glaube ähm ob
man jetzt per Geldspende hilft ob man
ein paar sachspendet die Helfer vor Ort
ich glaube jeder kann da seinen Beitrag
dazu leisten und zumindest ein bisschen
und ich glaube jetzt ist einfach an der
Zeit dass alle Hand in Hand gehen und
alle gemeinsam was tun
und ich hätte mir gewünscht dass es so
ein Video auf meinem Kanal nie gegeben
müsste
aber immerhin kann man so jetzt alle was
gutes tun und mein herzliches Beileid
und alle die Familie oder Freunde
verloren haben tut mir wirklich sehr
leid